it's the kind of business idea that you
can only come up with if you've remained
a child at heart the staff look on
enraptured as firm Sterling's newest
model is put through its paces its
Stephenson's rocket l1 which was built
in England in 1829 but something isn't
quite working as it should
20 people work here and fiddling around
is part and parcel of the job
the small components are painstakingly
assembled by hand until everything works
like clockwork
Herman berm is the company's CEO he
started building miniature model engines
two decades ago model vintage cars are a
successful new line this model of a 1915
40 the first ever automobile to go into
mass production is one of the products
that's proving popular which DiSpirito
schlemiel the ethanol flame heats up the
air in the back of the chamber so that
it expands and moves forward into the
cooler area and is turned into
mechanical energy there the differences
in temperature propel the piston rods
it's as simple as that there's a
continual movement from hot to cold and
back again when the Scottish pastor
Robert Stirling invented the hot air
engine in 1816 he was looking for a way
of pumping water more easily his engine
even competed with the steam engine for
a while but few people have heard of
Stirling today
in Fujian I determine in the 1950s
Philips tried to build a new and more
powerful version of the hot air engine
that production was seized maybe because
it wasn't an economic success or perhaps
because the oil lobby was too strong at
the moment Greenpeace has a low
temperature Stirling motor on its
homepage which enables water to be
pumped in Africa with solar energy or
with warm water channeled from roof
pipes to that extent it's a really great
thing it's fulfilling the Sicilian
specific oil temporarily through a
spanner in the works of the Stirling
Motors progress but only temporarily
perhaps Burma is convinced that its I
will come he wants to make the principle
of the hot air engine better known the
miniatures are produced to scale on the
computer but the actual production
depends on classic engineering methods a
miniature machine like this will set you
back anything from 150 euros upwards
these models stand on the desks of
hundreds of executives worldwide and the
next project is already on the planning
board to build a miniature of this
classic helicopter that's why he has a
full-scale one parked outside the engine
specialist is fascinated by the way that
everything on it moves he really likes
the idea of seeing this too on his or
someone else's desk I know mine is good
one of my first customers told me that
he found it really calming to just sit
back and watch it run on the desk in
front of him that's the real fascination
watching old technology in action on
your desk in an increasingly virtual
world berms miniature desktops are
reassuringly solid and straightforward